Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames
Messieurs chers collègues l'exercice
auquel nous venons d'assister tient du
rituel un rituel presque mécanique et
qui l' plus encore aujourd'hui un
catalogue une succession de promesses
diverses et varié sans lien entre elles
et de niveau pour le moins inégal assez
éloigné d'un discours de politique
général mais ce n'est pas faire un jour
à Monsieur le Premier Ministre de
constater que son intervention n'est que
la revue de détail d'une déclaration de
politique générale que le Président de
la République avait fait avant lui et du
coup à sa place à l'occasion d'une
conférence de presse fleuve oh vous
comme nous et surtout comme le pays
subissons l'intempérance
jupitérienne il est vrai que le nouvel
équilibre institutionnel du quinena a
trop souvent ravalé et c'est malheureux
le rôle du Premier ministre à celui d'un
simple figurant un communicant un
collaborateur comme dirait un ancien
président avec Emmanuel Macron cette
atrophie institutionnelle est encore
aggravée par la conception autocentrée
qu'il se fait du pouvoir le président
est ministre de tout et évidemment le
premier d'entre eux pour aller
directement au fait je n'ai pas vu dans
ce discours de politique générale qui
tombe lourdement d'une des fenêtres du
château les voix et moyen du
redressement je n'ai pas senti le grand
souffle qui puisse emporter le pays vers
des lendemains heureux et pour tout dire
je n'ai senti aucun
souffle il ne suffit pas d'invoquer une
volonté de mettre fin au conservatisme
pour bousculer un système sclérosé par
des décennies de politiquement correct
de connivance de bétonnage de rend de
situation pas toujours légitime force de
constater que non seulement vous n'y
êtes pas parvenu mais tout au contraire
vous poursuivez un modèle andogamique et
oligarchique dont votre Ministre madame
ouea Castera apparaît comme
l'incarnation
archétypale et puis il y a le fond la
valangeche de promesses à laquelle nous
venons d'assister ne nous laisse
entrevoir qu'une réponse à quelques
urgences médiatiques comme s'il
s'agissait de gagner du temps je ne vois
rien en effet qui contribue au
redressement des piliers effondrés vous
continuez à porter une vision
utilitariste construite autour de
mesurettes sans transcendance ni portée
et surtout une vision fondamentalement
postpitique et poste national dans ce
catalogue de mesures épart et parfois
contradictoire vous tentez d'allier un
peu de droite et un peu de gauche et en
réalité vous accommoder le pire de la
droite et le pire de la
gauche le pire de la
droite c'est par exemple la hausse des
franchises médicales ou la nouvelle
réforme à venir du chômage le pire de la
gauche la hausse des taxes sur
l'électricité ou la normalisation à
outran je pense bien sûr au DPE qui fait
tant de mal au secteur du logement et le
bilan financier de vos politiques est
apparu il y a quelques jours un déficit
budgétaire de l'État proche du record de
l'année
2020 la situation exige une remise à
plat d'une autre ampleur un grand
mouvement appuyé sur une volonté
nationale sur la force retrouvée de
l'État et sur une volonté populaire qui
légitime l'action publique en clair la
souveraineté l'état la
démocratie la première condition est de
rendre au pays sa capacité de décider et
votre arrimage aveugle et inconditionnel
sur l'agenda bruxellois vous condamne
d'office aux mêmes Herms que vos
prédécesseurs à quoi riment les discours
sur le volontarisme lorsque vous savez
que vous avez laissé les commandes
intellectuelles et institutionnelles à
l'autorité supranationale de l'Union
européenne à quoi bon les déclarations
sur l'agriculture au-dessus de tout
lorsque vous êtes prisonnier des
logiques décroissantistes du wisme vert
appuyz sur des ballots de paille vous
parlez de souveraineté française quand
l'Élysée use et abuse d'un oxyort d'une
incantation antinomique la souveraineté
européenne alors que la très mercantile
Union européenne a depuis toujours
révoqué le mot souveraineté pour s'en
remettre de manière obsessionnelle à la
seule loi du marché pensez monsieur le
prier ministre qu'au moment même où les
agriculteurs français manifestaient à
Bruxelles devant le Parlement européen à
quelques mètres de là dans un immeuble
en vert vos élus du groupe Renaissance
votter un nouvel accord de libre échange
désastreux avec le
Chili cela ne vous empêchez pas le
lendemain la main sur le cœur de
promettre aux agriculteurs français de
les
défendre les commentateurs amusés ils
verront les artifices en même temps moi
ces faux semblants m'inspirent la plus
grande peine pour nos agriculteurs pour
cette France rurale qui souffre pour
notre peuple que l'on trompe la
confiance pourtant si nécessaire en ces
temps de crise ne peut revenir dans
votre monde où l'on privilégie le court
terme l'éphémère l'apparence et où l'on
pense pouvoir éteindre les contestations
par des initiative dilatoire le mensonge
la ruse ou à l'usure il ne sert à rien
de vouloir écoper le bateau qui fait
haut quand les membres de l'équipage aux
ordres du commandant s'activent en même
temps à ouvrir des voies d'eau partout
dans la
coque quel crédit peut-on accorder à ces
incohérences avez-vous comme premier
ministre seulement prise sur ce qui se
passe sur ce qui est décidé sur ce
système qui a fait le choix résolu de la
vassalisation à Bruxelles du pacte vert
au pacte desmigration vos choix
politiques ressemblent de plus en plus à
des pactes faustiens on se perd en
conjjecture sur les bénéfices que vous
en tirer à moins que comme fa il
s'agisse seulement de gagner un peu plus
de temps de
jouissance il est parfois compliqué de
comprendre ce qu'est le macronisme et
vraisemblablement beaucoup même les
observateur averti serait incapable d'en
donner une définition précise une chose
est S
il s'agit d'une pensée liquide avec pour
perspective une société liquide parce
que pour
vous tout doit se résumer à des flux la
théorie du ruissellement vous sert à
servir les
nantilles le seul russellement qu'il y a
eu c'est celui de l'argent public qui a
coulé à flot avec votre cap vous avez
pour perspective de noyer la France dans
l'océan de la dette 900 milliards de
dettes supplémentaires en 7 ans autant
que le montant total de la dette
française en l'an
2000 cette liquidité que vous prenez
mène et c'est logique à la liquidation
Emmanuel Macron en tête vous mettez en
œuvre la grande déconstruction le grand
effacement de la France comme des
somnambules sans tenir compte des
réalités sociales ou de l'évolution du
monde qui s'ajoute à l'abrasion
naturelle du temps quand rien dans la
décision politique ne conduit au
dépassement
la première condition vous disais-je
c'était la souveraineté la seconde
condition c'est la restauration de
l'État et de ce point de vue je ne vois
pas dans votre déclaration de lueur
d'espoir la restauration de l'État
suppose de sortir de la grande confusion
politicoadministrative qui règne dans
nos institutions nationales ou locales
il est urgent de remettre de l'ordre
dans l'organisation publique avec le
gouvernement des sachants dont le
saint-simonisme ambiant a fait une
religion en France et en Europe
on assiste à un va et vient entre
fonction administrative et Politi entre
fonction publi et intérêt privés entre
fonction élective et aut magistrature il
en résulte une confusion profonde une
confusion dommageable pour la gestion
publique mais aussi la crédibilité des
institutions leur solidité leur
efficacité confusion politique lorsque
les politiques ont abdiqué leur
responsabilité et que le mot politique
devient synonyme d'uissance confusion
institutionnelle lorsque plus personne
ne sait qui fait quoi qui décide de quoi
et même qui est en état juridiquement de
décider le local le National le
Parlement le président le juge le
Conseil constitutionnel Bruxelles la
presse l'ut temp comble de paradoxe sous
la 5è qui lui en a qui lui en donne le
pouvoir le président ne préside pas il
gouverne et lorsque le président
gouverne le gouvernement se contente
d'administrer les affaires ire courante
que dire des régions qui ouvrent des
ambassades à l'étranger des communes qui
subventionnent sans objets municipal le
trafic d'être humain par le biais des
associations complices des passeurs d'un
clan politique qui saccage la capitale
de tous les Français d'un préfet de
police qui est incapable de faire cesser
les vendeurs à la sauvette sous la tour
effffel ou d'une préfecture qui
entretient des rapports troubles avec
des individus impliqués dans l'acte
terroriste de treèb pour nous au
rassemblement national il n a de
restauration de la puissance publiqueà
deux conditions la restauration de la
fonction publique la restauration des
moyens de l'État la question la grande
question qui est posée au pays n'est pas
seulement le programme de tel ou tel
gouvernement ce n'est pas la vision
seulement de tel ou tel président ce
n'est pas la bonne volonté supposée ou
réelle de tel ou tel ministre c'est le
retour du politique c'est au politique
qu'il appartient de décider et tout
particulièrement dans les ministères
dans les assemblées dans les régions ou
dans les communes l'élu doit arrêter de
se tourner vers le fonctionnaire pour se
faire souffler une décision et encore
moins une injonction les ministres
doivent cesser d'être les porte-paroles
serviles des directeurs d'administration
des féodalités bancaire de la grande
distribution ou des intérêts financiers
ils doivent redevenir les inspirateurs
des grandes impulsions publi dont le
pays a besoin le retour du politique
c'est aussi la pensée magique celle du
quoi qu'il en coûte ou celle il suffit
d'emprunter celle des experts ou des
grands prêtres de la pensée unique la
logique frileuse et désastreuse du pas
de vague quand il s'agit d'affronter les
problèmes à l'heure où vous parlez de
réarmement peut-être pour vous donner
des air guerriers je ne crois pas avoir
entendu l'expression réarmement régalien
ce n'est pas un oubli parce que ce n'est
pas votre projet pourtant la question
est d'importance la France est-elle
condamné à enfoncer dans le laxisme
judiciaire la politique peut- peut-elle
encore continuer à demander à la police
de terrain les solutions sécuritaire et
social qui relève justement du politique
et de lui seul l'entreprise peut-elle
supplier les carences de formation et
parfois même d'éducation c'est aux
politiques au pluriel de reprendre
conscience de leur rôle et confiance
dans leur vocation qui est celle de
décider librement de la vie de la cité
des régulations nécessaires des
sanctions lorsqu'elle participe au juste
et nécessaire équilibre social mais
c'est vrai cela demande du courage pour
reprendre le cardinal de Richelieu
fondateur de l'État la politique revient
à rendre possible ce qui est nécessaire
cela exige de la
persévérance le retour du
politique implique en réalité la
détermination à reprendre le contrôle à
le reprendre sur les forces
supranationales comme l'Union européenne
sur les féodalités qui gangrainent la
vie sociale et
économique sur les inerties
administratives ou d'habitude sur la
résignation de l'opinion lassée des
échecs de ces dirigeants et le moyen le
bras armé de cette reprise de contrôle
c'est l'état pour peu qu'il soit
respecté c'est-à-dire restaurer la
restauration de l'État c'est la
réhabilitation des grands corps
préfectoral ou corps diplomatique le
retour du sens de l'État et au plus près
des gens partout sur le territoire en
métropole et en outrem la proximité des
services publics c'est un état conscient
qui n'agit pas pour lui mais au service
de la nation un état conscient que son
premier devoir est la sécurité
intérieure et extérieure l'égalité des
citoyens et la liberté de tous c'est un
état dont les agents sont honorés
respectés et récompensés comme le mérite
le service qu'il consacre au pays c'est
un état doté des moyens de ses
missions la TR condition du redassement
c'est la démocratie c'est-à-dire le
retour du peuple ou de ses représentants
quoi que vous puissiez dire sur votre
prétendu changement de méthode Monsieur
le Premier Ministre on ne peut que
constater votre incapacité à sortir des
logiques verticales à votre décharge
après c ans de pouvoir d'Emmanuel Macron
je ne crois pas que vous puissiez
modifier ce qui apparaît être une marque
de fabrique du macronisme votre discours
sonnait d'ailleurs comme un cruel
réquisitoire des 7 ans d'Emmanuel Macron
vous n'avez pas de majorité au lieu d'en
chercher une par le respect de vos
alliés par l'écoute par le dialogue et
éventuellement par le compromis vous
comptez sur des ruses institutionnelles
en excluant par principe les voies
transparentes et saines de trouver
l'assise majoritaire dont vous avez
besoin l'élaboration de la loi par des
493 la mitrailleuses les décisions
publiques au marteau ou les atteintes au
droit d'amendement au nom de prétendu
cavalier ne sont pas admissibles dans
une démocratie moderne lorsque le
Conseil constitutionnel participe au
détricotage arbitraire de l'expression
de la représentation parlementaire par
une lecture militante de la Constitution
il en ressort une impression de dénis
démocratique un piétinement du principe
même de la
démocratie bon enfin qui peut croire que
le délit de séjour irrégulier n'aurait
rien à voir avec l'immigration et à ce
titre devrait être effacé de la loi un
pays ne peut pas sans conséquence
psychologiques passer des lois sans vote
et parfois sans débat ignorer les
contestations sociales réprimer les
expression des souffrances populaires ou
jouer avec une délectation cynique la
stratégie du pourrissement le respect de
la volonté du peuple fondement de la
démocratie nul ne devrait pouvoir s'en
affranchir vous devez cesser de
considérer l'exercice de la démocratie
comme une formalité administrative la
conduite de l'État comme un pass-ant les
institutions comme des instruments les
fonctions ministérielles comme un jeu de
chaise musicale ce que nous attendons
d'un gouvernement c'est qu' finisse
clairement la grande voie autour de
laquelle doit s'articuler toute action
publique toute projection pour l'avenir
nous n'avons rien vu de tout cela ni
depuis 7 ans ni
aujourd'hui je vous
remercie